what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
alright so the cool thing about Justice
League versus Suicide Squad is that this
story is very structured and in fact
Justice League issue number 12 and
Suicide Squad issue number 9 are
actually pre ludes Justice League number
12 covers really like the new origin of
Maxwell Lord will it really kind of
cover it kind of fills in the gaps we
will cross that bridge when we get to it
but it's basically taking all the pre
new 52 Maxwell Lords stuff with regards
to like the checkmate organization a lot
kind of stuff and it blends it in with
like the new 52 landscape and it doesn't
really really well but for this story
the Suicide Squad this is so cool
because I feel like the ways of stories
written by Rob Williams is that it
really just like it highlights how dark
Amanda Waller is not only that is going
to show us why this group is the
original Suicide Squad and I'm kind of
glad this was written because when I
first jumped in to Justice League versus
Suicide Squad number one I was like okay
how did they become Suicide Squad that
was the question that I had and I was
really hoping that that tie in would
cover that and I'm glad I was right
about this but the way this is done the
team is effectively led by Rustom now
Rustin where I guess Russ damn I'm not
really sure exactly how you pronounce
that ah but the way he was originally
introduced in DC Comics was that he was
like an enemy of the Suicide Squad but
as far as I'm aware and as far as I've
been able to dig and I've dug I've done
Doug long and hard I am NOT able to
really find anything on like his origin
story in terms of why he was an enemy of
the to a side squad it's just that
somewhere along the line after the
Suicide Squad was reinvented under John
ah surrender after crisis on Infinite
Earths Rick Flagg led the team and they
just ran into rust him and they just
fought for a while and so what seems to
be happening here with regards to Rob
Williams writing is it seems to be just
as much going through and read conning
as it is ah you know providing a little
bit of history here kind of tapping into
the original things now that's really
the basis behind Justice League vs
Suicide Squad a lot of ways I mean this
Suicide Squad right here suicide zero
this team never existed before this is
the first time were ever seeing them and
so ah what DC's doing is retconning it
now for those of you guys who don't know
retcon stands for retroactive continuity
and what it means is something just like
this chronologically in terms of DC's
publication history this Suicide Squad
never exists but what Rob Williams is
saying is that before the original
Suicide Squad that you read about
whether you're reading the comics or
you're going through you know Wikipedia
or what-have-you
this team existed know by
ever knew about it and so that's kind of
the cool thing here but all these people
are really kind of brought in here I
mean Lobo emerald Emperor cyclotron
Johnny Sark
you know dr. Clark's they're all brought
here for the purpose of carrying out a
mission according to Amanda Waller this
is her first foray into this and the
problem here is that Amanda Waller
basically presents them with an
incentive-based scenario and that's the
difference with regards to the main
Suicide Squad and the Suicide Squad here
this is really just kind of a team
that's formed through bribery I mean
it's really Amanda Waller she quite
literally says I will give you your
heart's desire if you carry out the
mission as I ask you to now of course
we'll find out what this mission is here
in a second but in response to me this
is we're talking about Lobo being paid
money you know we're talking about
Johnny sorrow being given people to kill
it's all kinds of crazy things as
opposed to like the traditional Suicide
Squad where Amanda Waller is basically
like hey if you go out here and do these
missions then life will be a little bit
easier for you you're not gonna get your
heart's desire we'll just make life a
little bit easier now the mission itself
is really like an allegory to North
Korea as far as I'm aware yang sung
there's a guy that doesn't exist I mean
I was kind of poking around cause
there's been a few times where I've been
like and then this person who existed in
the real world but of course the Robin
Corps is like no Rob that's actually
wrong it's important that I tell you
that you're um which is kind of funny to
me it cracks me up but nonetheless this
is basically just a crazy guy I mean
it's a dude who just exists you know in
his own country he's the leader of the
country and he's testing his own weapons
and it's really the idea that he
possesses the potential to implement a
massive amount of destruction in the
United States
quite literally obliterating California
now that was the basis and that still
remains the basis behind the suicide
squad the suicide squad carries out
missions that are basically suicidal so
that if any of them die they're just
easily replaceable they're villains that
no one would miss villains that nobody
really cares about there's no one that
you know no one that's tied to their
stories they're basically just
disposable people now the way this is
done is is Amanda Waller says you know
there are these metahumans you know in
this this territory called the Yongsan
gods but in her mind she doesn't have or
at least that the Suicide Squad doesn't
have all the information that like no
one really knows the information in fact
Amanda Waller doesn't really have it all
instead all they know is that there are
just these young Sun gods no one really
has any idea what's going on with them
the issue is that when the Suicide Squad
gets in there they're told kill the
leader kill the yang Sun gods to destroy
the weapon that they're using call it a
day get out of
and comeback the problem is when they
get through there for every god they
kill a thousand people die and no one
knows why I mean Amanda Waller's like
what the hell is going on right now you
know people are starting to freak out
not only that when she begins to realize
that there would be catastrophic effects
she starts to call them back now an
important thing to keep in mind here is
that Amanda Waller is us is she's a
heartless there's no other way to
say it and we love that about her that's
why we love Amanda Waller because she's
ruthless
I mean she's cold and ruthless and
someone she calls back the Suicide Squad
it's not because she's like oh my
goodness all these people are dying how
terrible she's just like this would
create a firestorm for me for the
Suicide Squad it would create so many
issues River the Suicide Squad is
supposed to be a black ops team they're
supposed to be under the radar no one is
really supposed to know about them or at
least their actions are not supposed to
be overt and so because of that if they
go into a country and for every yang Sun
god they kill a thousand people die
thousands of people are going to die and
someone's going to notice that and so
because of this the Suicide Squad the
fact that they're not controllable
basically say no we're finishing the
mission now rust in a told Amanda Waller
about this he said look the guys you
have here their loyalty is only with
whatever you can pay them and so the
Lori's not to you their loyalties not to
the mission their loyalty is to the
reward and so if you say come back and
I'm not going to give you the reward
they're gonna complete the mission
because they want their money or they
want whatever it is that was promised to
them and that's exactly what the Suicide
Squad does they go through Johnny sorrow
everybody they just start killing off
these young Sun gods and all these
people start dying and so what they
eventually do is they essentially come
across the weapon that was creating
these gods and what we learned is it was
basically using life energy that it was
tapping into the brain waves the brain
patterns of everybody you know and yang
Seung to essentially power these gods so
because of that whenever it was that
they killed a yang Sun God it basically
cut off that person's brainwaves it
basically just shut their brain down is
really what it did and so what happens
here is Amanda Waller says you know look
you guys need to leave you guys need to
go and initially they're like okay fine
that I guess maybe we could take off if
we could just destroy the weapon now
this is when cyclotrons steps didn't
know the funny thing about cyclotron is
he's an old-school DC character he's
almost like he's like Hawkeye in terms
of his circumstances in the sense
that he was just kind of in the wrong
place at the wrong time the difference
is that the Hawkeye eventually became a
good guy a cyclotron didn't he just kind
of stayed a bad guy but he never really
wanted to be a bad guy the issue with
his character though and as far as I've
been able to tell there's virtually
nothing on this guy I mean this dude is
almost non-existent and what this does
is it allows Rob Williams to basically
just do whatever he wants with this
character and that's usually how it
works in comic books when a writer comes
along and they grab a character that has
almost no involvement in the DC
landscape whatsoever whether involvement
is is marginal then it basically allows
the rider to do whatever they want to
because there's just these huge gaps in
their publication history where no one
knew what they were doing and so it was
really easy for Rob Williams to come
along and say well let's just grab this
guy now the reason why he grabs
cyclotron was that because you know
cyclotron was in and of himself just an
atomic bomb that's basically what he is
you know he's powered by atomic energy
not only that he's a he's a genius you
know when it comes to all these
different forms of science and so what
he says is hey look guys if this thing
was being made or this this machine was
being used to manipulate the brain
patterns of young saeng citizens for the
purpose of basically creating these
young Sun gods giving like the actual
power to these young Sun gods they could
do whatever they want to do well then we
can do the exact same thing except we
can expand its capabilities and we can
literally just immerse the world and
then suddenly we have just these young
Sun gods that are on this massive level
of power and they can take out you know
all these different superheroes and
maybe they can basically allow us to
rule everything now of course the
response of the of the The Suicide Squad
is well hell why not I mean we got this
far we might as well do it now not
everyone's on board I mean of course you
know you got Lobo who just wants to
destroy stuff so he's like yeah I'm not
really on board with this you know and
some of them actually end up you know
end up bailing out for a time while
others stay behind the issue is that
Amanda Waller goes to Lobo you know
communicating to him and says look you
need to kill cyclotron now on the
surface the idea seems to be the
cyclotron is the one that can
essentially you know manipulate this
machine or he's the one controlling it
that if they kill cyclotron it'll sort
of bring everything back to normal the
problem with this is that once Lobo goes
in there while cyclotron tries to talk
him out of it
Lobo eventually just kills him anyway
because in his mind a deal's a deal now
this all really kind of goes back to the
idea of Lobo
yeah he's a mass murderer yeah he's
crazy as hell but honor is one of the
more important things to him and so he
says look I made a deal I I made a
promise I basically made a bargain
somebody you know you can't offer me
anything that'll get me to break that
bargain all you're doing is just
pleading for your life it's time for you
to die the problem with this is that
Rustin responds and says why did you do
that you know and he's like well I mean
you know Amanda Waller wanted me to you
know she she told me that she'd she'd
pay me to do so you know and and Russell
says dude the guy was basically an
atomic bomb he was a safety device that
if you guys run off and you do something
stupid that with you being the easiest
person to manipulate because all you
want is money plus you're a person is
virtually indestructible when it comes
to atomic bombs but all she has to do is
just agree to pay you more and then
you'll kill him basically detonating an
atomic bomb and that's exactly what
happens this atomic energy of my Quran
just begins to essentially detonate and
it seems as though it wipes out the
entirety of the suicide squad as it's
seen here now this is why I say Amanda
Waller is so ruthless because what she
does is she says I didn't like the way
things turned out but in the end the
Suicide Squad did their job you know for
the most part their bodies aren't
physically destroyed they're they're you
know they're basically being held in
stasis what she says they did their job
now as long as you're alive is because
they're basically either they're tied
into mysticism they're tied into magic
they have extremely high durability I
mean there was a reason why they were
chosen so that if things went to pot and
something like this happened you know
Amanda Waller could basically just kind
of sweep them under the rug call it off
and then go back reinvent the Suicide
Squad team and possibly pluck one or two
of them out of stasis and then throw
them back onto a team again with a new
charter with a new mindset on how they
function but it's basically her just
kind of keeping things under control
keeping things under wraps but in the
end this is why she's so cold-blooded if
she says yeah I mean we set off a
nuclear bomb we wiped out a huge portion
of the city those individuals who were
who were alive in that area it doesn't
matter they're all dead
the mission was a success and that's all
she cares about for her it's just like
the mission was a success
everything else is just details well
develop a cover story we'll make up some
reason you know we'll just say well they
were testing a nuclear bomb and it went
bad and it all blew up and that was it
you know and and and it's it's it's
cold-blooded but this is the pre loo to
Justice League versus Suicide Squad what
this will do is segue directly into
Justice League versus sue escazu aside
squad number one and so what I'm gonna
do is I'm actually gonna tie this I'm
gonna take the Justice League versus
Suicide Squad playlist or videos that
I'm just gonna throw those into the DC
rebirth playlist as a whole which by the
way if you guys don't know about
you'll find the playlist down in the
description it's all the the DC rebirth
stuff just organized by character and
I'm gonna kind of throw it all together
that way creates just one cohesive story
but if you guys are new here to Commons
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]